got zero eyes on her bioma fingers
crossed it's not too late so you
oh i hate this life or death [ __ ] hurry
try hacking the door
think you can trip it on your own v
[Music]
a profile
uh
[Music]
xander dorset's protected under echelon
2 corporal immunity
our girls top shelf this one's packing
black market zeta tech repros
typical back alley fix-ups not our lucky
girl
let's keep looking you know
i saw him
[Music]
[Music]
one
[Music]
don't see any movement on the sensors
looks like you got them
clear to go the hell's on target
look around gotta be there somewhere
oh
layout shows only one room left the
bathroom go
sure hope our target's in there
jesus christ
[Music]
i think i got her got her target we make
it
she alive about to find out v
jack into our biomod need to know what
we're dealing with
this does not look good checking in
sandra dorsett nc 570442
trauma team platinum platinum [ __ ]
trauma
get her out terrace
[Music]
patient on the ground
five steps back now
tt-133 to control patient nc570442
secured
stimulus being administered 70
milligrams dopamine
110 norepinephrine 800
let's get out of here elevator gets us
to the garage direct
good work is over
cutting my wires now see in the near
future
you